16 años después del huracán katrina que
dejó casi 2.000 muertos luisiana está
enfrentando su peor huracán en más de un
siglo clasificado como huracán de
categoría 4 aida tocó tierra este
domingo 29 de agosto el mismo día que
katrina en 2005 justo después que
luisiana fuera devastada el presidente
george bush lamentaba las consecuencias
de su desgracia este va a ser un camino
difícil de foco road
los retos a los que nos enfrentamos
sobre el terreno no tienen precedentes
pero no me cabe duda de que vamos a
tener éxito
ahora mismo los días parecen muy oscuros
para los afectados lo entiendo
con más de 800 mil desplazados generando
alrededor de 146 mil millones de dólares
en daños materiales katrina fue la
catástrofe natural más costosa de la
historia de eeuu la ciudad de nueva
orleans la más impactada por el huracán
tomó casi 10 años para recuperarse de
los daños pero porque duró tanto tiempo
en sus memorias publicadas en 2010 el ex
presidente george bush apuntó una falla
que muchos habían criticado en la época
me enorgullezco de mi habilidad para
tomar decisiones claras y efectivas aún
así tras el katrina eso no ocurrió el
problema no fue que yo tomara malas
decisiones fue que me tomé mucho tiempo
para decidir una demora que escandalizó
a todo un país
en primera instancia george bush había
declarado justo después del impacto de
katrina que nadie le había informado
sobre las posibles consecuencias del
huracán un año después salí a la
grabación de una videoconferencia con
los servicios de emergencia donde
expertos le advertían sobre las amenazas
de las llegadas del katrina
houston